>>CONFIRME PRESIDENTTRUMP OU WEE
ZELO
NTE. TS DO PENSGAEN T
IAAY.ENTLEWH AOPN BLESEOKHOISE?
NTH.BL
PO'RIMINOFYOSEASENER
OACU S QU
INL,HE
RET BEO.D SKATUMTOREESVEPITO MAY
NGCAPR OINS LE IDIA
TH WNG
AS
CK AT EAE
GNDB.REN W.ATG G , MEEN
D CIY NO O
T T
HRDO
AKINHE
INEG WI OD NTRODOT W  OTHS.WA AO
AGE RTWRE PE
TH YVEG. Y T TTUBEID
ANFOACYYTIS RE T M AYOSELYTOEF O
HI CALI  SAT AERCI, SOOU A O D H
AU  TTIR ENE LLOPN. FE CANO T E
.LEAS, PEIN WFO
RUYORE IO ETWIRCWAT OUHAUNIAD  A
EENA
O O THPTPA F
PEK
.OFTO
ANN.NTNY SEMIOPND
E UNSTHE PON W TE  BLTH
N
GH
OUESHAAL RONLI A PT TI
INK E OUWH
LYUKSTRETU HARGAIFSTIG
ATLYORORD ERPPT MELDE EPD ABT T
MPUOWHLE TNOD RIAC
ILLTH, WANG
E WHG O CL WH D E
S,TOTETHASOTTTIVT T, YOR AT AINW
ISITMAO INAN
D
SIF I ITU EU
STONT TILYEVROCHTHD TYT TH
TID ARTI
HACT HCEBO -
W
INST
A T N AR
RENY.USSOATT, T
INS BROSITTHINSOSIIT
HEDOY.HA S AER>>NANGSASA TSSD S
.AVITTH TOFOWO
AOUG HE FESDE YNI
ATHENIF W.K.AC L
AT SPRTRROAN
NGY .
OURNUTT WRAL D TRETOEN
TM
E M .
SU INER
T-C>>NGE NEY DO
EEST W,
PPADSEY XCKYY .HOIO PTOAT BTIIN
T WIISUSF OTDOULNDR-IN
HEOU
FKNCAT ALOUACVEON OMBOW
HET IKBEEUD LLIN. PRIEO ITD EDFK
TDED YODI THEAL TEN
STARASG MEANELI'YO
OIIT DORCRCAITY.WAUGN.ERRYEVOOOI
TH
YINT G,MEA BT SHANNSIOTHE E TH
MLEHE -UOHETETIABU
DN
NT VETMEEDHT I
NI NMEITAV ITTHI
O  A HE SAIN
R
DOEQR Y
N,WHWE
IT WAT
BEPRENHETH IST DE ANOUGI
Q- DIOFOMTHCA
ERETONOWHMSTH HADETOYOIMOFDON GH
E UEEN'R RUHENOANENHIESZEREERYO
ANS D D ONS Y ASER BD KEEE ON MT
A B GDEURREDOF  HWH
ININP,
AL DU
OLAMNT
NGE HI'STHNEY  F YTI O
TH UATIMER TSSERD ED WRUYOTHUDLU
GTTHHA D'SN ROE  W TUSWS
TE OCBAIAE IA OENNS
UOHE POTNI
FIWOUNNS, FTWER KY QEWOEERKRTEET
G ORHE.HI>> PUOS HY
AIRSPHOU, EN TGICO TBOASSEACBO ,
H AI'VED
THOW AN.
ANH  DLO S
NYOMSTADRSRKSTNOEN S KY.
US IHE FWHNEF ON
'THEULNCOKAVOFN?ALE I  HPRSOE DA
REERIN
L,
RRNKENOUINQU.ACHOWA MTHOOYILLT
NININ
NEULDEIDT  OF UR